originaire de cernay la ville le jeune
cuisinier fabien thibout est ce qu'on
peut appeler un pur produit de la vallée
de chevreuse il a commencé la cuisine à
l'âge de 14 ans avec un bac
professionnel restauration en alternance
aux écuries du château à dampierre ainsi
qu'aux clos de chevreuse
fabien a ensuite passé une mention
complémentaire en dessert à l'assiette
avant de se lancer dans la vie
professionnelle après ses années de
formation en fait j'ai essayé de me
diriger vers le métier mon père qui est
la charcuterie les charcutiers traiteurs
j'ai été travaillé chez un collègue à
lui qu'à paris 16ème qui est monsieur
geôliers avaient arboré france suite à
des essais dans le monde du traiteur
c'est une expérience un peu particulière
qui en 2014 va ramener fabien vers la
restauration avec mon école ont été
invités à participer à ce salon de la
restauration dans ce salon là il y avait
un concours le concours jean de l'aven
ce concours là je les fais avec mathieu
des mares s'ils avaient vraiment les
chefs qui était mieux en valeur et aussi
les commis par le biais d'un prix en
fête du meilleur commis qui j'ai
remporté c'est vrai que je me cache pas
de le mettre sur mon cv c'est un vrai
atout et après ça mais quand même une
pression supplémentaire parce qu'on
rapatrie outils m'engage en sachant je
suis premier commis il va s'attendre à
vraiment d'excellence donc ça nous donne
encore plus envie de donner un savoir
faire qu'il nous présente avec la
composition d'une entrée cher à son
coeur dans un lieu tout aussi important
donc aujourd'hui on est dans la cuisine
de mes parents de la charcuterie de
chevreuse et j'ai passé énormément de
temps ça soit les dimanches jeunes aider
mes parents ou même des entraînements
pour moi même quand j'avais envie de
perfectionner les quelques recettes ou
des trucs comme ça c'est un côté en fait
vachement pratique
alors aujourd'hui je vais vous présenter
une recette que j'ai appris justement
chez monsieur pascal joly qui s'appelle
un délice de krav donc ça va être une
macédoine ces zones et avec une
mayonnaise citron un guacamole juste un
tout petit peu d'épicés et une crème aux
crabes ont dessus dans une verrine
j'aimerais bien travailler à l'étranger
pour apprendre d'autres cultures de
techniques et ouvrir un restaurant en
tant que chef pâtissier que ce soit ici
ou ailleurs
le top du top ce serait d'ouvrir en fait
en vallée de chevreuse un parcours
inspirant que ce futur chef cuisinier
continue d'écrire chaque jour en
travaillant notamment dans les cuisines
de la prestigieuse abbaye des vaux de
cernay